I didn't realize I've been listening to
Nick crawls voice in my house over and
over again because I didn't realize
until last night that he's in the film
sing-sing is a big hit right now in the
in the Robert's family home and I didn't
realize until yesterday it was me
playing goon tear yes yeah look we're
just talking I shot something reason I
looked at myself and I hate looking at
myself
do you like look at yourself no no I
can't stop it's like oh this is what
Hades is yeah it's like having to watch
yourself over and over but I yeah no I
hate it and I have to like when it's
something of mine I have to watch it
three or four times before I can begin
to like give notes on it because about
the content because all I'm doing is
watching me like okay well my note is my
fat face and my shitty forehead and my
double chin and then my stupid fat
stomach so yeah do we have a different
me we could put in its networks do you
figure out a way to separate yourself
from it eventually where you're like I'm
not even gonna consciously be aware that
that's me
because otherwise I'll never get out of
this I just literally have to watch it a
few times
and then and then I'm just having a lot
of work done I'm just getting I'm
getting my eyes done I'm gonna shave a
little off the chin yeah shave the
bridge in the nose a little bit getting
my dick done yeah I should have my dick
worked on yeah yeah it's great it's it
looks great oh yeah yeah yeah we'll get
into it I'm wanded with sound waves yeah
to do what
it just is regenerates tissue it like
these little law
you're coming for for Eastern medicine
on your dick yeah no no it's rich its
Western yes yeah sure it's Western grip
yeah Wow so just like regenerates tissue
yeah these causes these little teeny
micro tears inside and then the tissue
regenerates when you have to pump your
dick twice it's a whole thing
Wow yeah but it actually helps is have
you noticed a difference yeah yeah
in your hard-ons you know yeah they're
more frequent and I'm also not
masturbating as much which helps to come
after a while it was just like oh right
already I got it yeah cowering but yeah
it does actually if there's a lot better
I've tried to curb my masturbation it's
hard right yeah I just well I tried to
curb my porn consumption can you do when
you're not even horny you just do it
it's like eating when you're not hungry
yeah doing well it's like you run out of
ambien you're like I gotta go to bed I'm
gonna watch some porn go to sleep
is that also because we all are I guess
have the one of the last generations to
know what it was like mentally before
porn was just all-consuming everywhere
yeah so like you you're like I want to
get back to when I could get excited
just looking at like a swimsuit issue or
something yeah I want to bottle the
smell of a porn magazine yeah you
remember that oh yes there's different
ones who was the high gloss wand yeah
magazine and then there was the smell of
old magazines you can find them in the
woods with your friends yes yeah
someone's old Playboy stash yeah oh yeah
all of them what was the most exciting
real triggers I don't know I mean I also
have a the smell of like certain
moisturizers like I remember as being
like early lubricant oh wow so I'm like
dude [ __ ] I'm just well what would you
like something like a like a hand cream
exactly like that like a weird fancy
hand cream from the guest bathroom
oh really yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
that's gonna sting so I never got into
hand cream for that reason yeah it was
too cold going on yeah and then it was
just uncomfortable after a while so with
Lube it's very difficult but that's
amazing like you go to a friend's house
and they have like Jerkins or whatever
in the bathroom and you just like you
just think you're lotioning up your
hands and you go oh my god yeah you
still use creamer Lube or no good sort
of yeah more of a lubricant now that I'm
called pure is really good pjur these be
called euros it works really well
now is that you hoping to get some free
no I can't lube sponsor dude I have so
much they couldn't give me any more than
I already have
there's nothing that you give me that I
don't already only
I go through that stuff really III buy
back your highly yes a lot I know yeah
that's why he has a Costco membership
Costco's got the best loop but it's hard
it's hard to quit that stuff it's really
so you must love doing animation cuz you
don't have to watch yourself you're just
getting exactly I don't have to watch
myself I don't have to put on any makeup
I don't have to put up wit on on have to
do anything I just show up in two voices
all day and then leave it's great yeah
it's the best it was a perfect thing out
of something like Kroll show which I was
doing all these characters it was a
great time but it just was physically
exhausting so animation is a kind of a
great way to kind of be able to do both
of those things and yeah it's where all
the show is is all about jerking off
yeah I mean it seems like you can work
through a lot of your own [ __ ] as well
like all your insecurities that like
haunt you when you're looking at
yourself yeah you actually get to work
through like there's there's lots of
stuff about having a little dick in
there yeah when you're a kid and trying
to figure it out so yeah it's a show
about me it's based on me and my best
friend from childhood and rude goldberg
about going through puberty so it's a
boy two kids one who's like super like
in season two one of the first things
that happens is based on something that
really happen to Andrew which was he had
that little like pubie mustache that
those kids that kids get and his father
made his mom waxes off the upper lip and
she waxed his lip and then he could grow
a beard like you know he could grow a
full beard at like 13 14 years old but
no hair on his upper lip because it had
been waxed through the root and so he
had he was missing hair here for years
and it looked literally like we would
call it his reverse Hitler and and but I
was like a super late bloomer I didn't
hit puberty until I don't know like
really into high school like I didn't
grow pubes I couldn't masturbate like
but I was I was so it's about these kids
who were like best friends were kind of
everything in common except what's
happening to them physically and and for
me I was like so aware of what was going
on around me my that my friends were
jerking off that they at all and I just
was like I had an imp you Bertie I was I
actually got pantsed like in sixth grade
seven
grade whereas you know girl like pull
down my pants and pull down my underwear
you know in front hairless ya you know
front of my like middle school crush the
girl that I was in love with throughout
elementary middle school and now I'm a
comedian yeah you never leave no and so
and see so it's about that and it's
season to the big new character is the
shame wizard which also I think is a
pervasive thing that never leaves you
Andrew gets caught jerking off to my
sister's bathing suit and the shame
wizard sort of sees that and then begins
to haunt him and slowly haunts the rest
of the kids because I think it's around
puberty middle school that's the idea of
shame really enters in and takes over
people's lives and either sticks around
or not depending on how you deal with it
the first time you jerked off were you
watching anything or no I the first time
I well I was like kind of playing with
myself you know cuz just you know figure
and [ __ ] out the first time I came I was
looking at a Victoria Secrets catalog
and I but I was weirdly wearing a condom
why cuz my I went to my I had an older
brother he had condoms and I was like I
just want to try on a condom see what
it's like then I just started kind of
messing around and it just happened to
be so the first time you came you you
were jerking off with a condom on yeah
and it's still and it's the last time
that that worked yeah no it was it but
it was this weird you know it's like all
the shows kind of about all that stuff
you know about boys and girls girls
figuring out that like you know we kind
of talked about the girls were horny too
and and figuring out what's going on
with their bodies and you know so it's
it's a lot of that so it is weirdly
therapeutic it's yeah you spending a lot
of time stuff that I literally talking
about in therapy I'm then in the room
the next day being like you know still
going through that stuff that pants
pulled down oh with the little hairless
penis and the girl who has the crush on
you
that's like literally that's somebody
that never leaves like that's again like
uses your comic that's that's the that's
right there the root of a state when I
when I saw it on the cartoon I was like
please God let this not be a true story
yeah well it is so it's a true story
that truly did happen to me and it and
it definitely had a truly lasting impact
on me Jessie she laughs at you no but I
have a very clear memory of her like
looking at me like looking at me and
then looking down and me being like this
is and then like pulling up my pants and
the girl who did it was like didn't mean
to pull down everything but I was
wearing silk boxer shorts exactly I
thought it was like a little Hefner yeah
and and and the girl who did it to me
was the girl the first girl to grow
boobs like you know like all of a sudden
there's that girl who just matures yes
and every guy is into her and sexualizes
her and the girls then feel bad about
their body and maybe like [ __ ] shame or
and that sort of what a lot of season
two is about as well and and it was yeah
it was that stuff doesn't leave you in
it and sorry what was there there was I
can't remember where we were there was
some point I was trying to make that I
don't remember but I think it's true
story and being therapeutic lock yeah
all of it it's so true and so weirdly
therapeutic - it is it - now talk about
it and deal with it it is like it starts
to take truly take some of the power and
and terribleness away from it because I
think also within that like season it's
really about this shame lizard and how
we kind of haunts all these kids in
different ways and I think one of the
things about shame is it's like when you
don't talk about these things like you
don't you don't actually begin to delve
into what they are and and and and shame
kind of grows its power through that I
wouldn't have any jokes if it wasn't for
shame like literally I also don't think
of something I just look at shame ago so
what do you think that's how it is yeah
yeah
always and when you talk about it people
think oh you shouldn't think you don't
know I'm just kind of vocalizing what's
yeah there I'm not saying it for an
effect from you but you realize that
everybody had a horrible childhood right
like you realize some level it's not
like this unique thing where you were
the only one that got humiliated yeah I
think that's a big part of the show for
us is it like on a like level of like oh
well hopefully everybody will identify
with what's that what happens here of
like god I couldn't stop masturbating or
like God
got pants in front of the girl I liked
or God my boobs got big and and I wasn't
ready for it or I didn't have boobs and
I felt terrible about myself that
everybody now then as we look back on it
had that experience and kids now are
going through that themselves that like
it the the you know cheesy version of it
is that like you're not alone
because I think so puberty feels like
you're so alone going through this like
that you're this disgusting creature
that has these crazy desires and habits
and and not realizing like everybody's
going through that yeah you feel unique
and horrible but nobody don't talks
about it right when you're really young
no one talks about being embarrassed or
feeling like a piece of [ __ ] everyone's
just kind of putting on a front like
everything's okay yeah and even the
people that do are adults and you don't
believe them you know what I mean
because you're not hearing it from
classmates and people that are doing the
exact same thing have people that you
knew back then reached out to you and
been like oh yeah I remember that I
remember that bye sure yeah we have we
definitely have I mean we we still have
friends from that period of time you
know we have a you know the characters
are a bunch of different pieces from
different people but one of the stories
that we I'm still friends with this dude
is um one of our friends on the show
it's it's me and John Mulaney John
voices Andrew and then the the character
our friend J is voiced by Jason
Mantzoukas and it's a Malcolm of a few
different people but one of the things
that we had is our friend from that
period of time he used to [ __ ] his
pillow and so J on the show [ __ ] his
pillow a lot and and our friend was like
oh well I [ __ ] my pillow but I also
like later in grad school had a Gatorade
bottle that he filled with like a warm
sponge that he would have sex with
that's amazing how people created
flashlights yeah yeah it's truly he
really had the flashlight before it was
the photo I was never good at that stuff
guys that would put stuff in between I
tried how it's dirty yes I read a dirty
story one time about how someone had
hollowed out of banana and wrapped it in
electrical tape and like put water in it
or something like that
or I just I was doing something like one
of those Stewart Penthouse Forum oh yeah
yeah and I tried it you should try to
make one awful yeah yeah that might be
the only time I've tried
I tried some oh maybe something else one
more time never with objects I would
always cut open a coke can and try to
[ __ ] that and I just I just tried to
force it right into the natural holes
and one injured myself yeah yeah lots of
room lots of room yeah I was never good
at that though I'd never good at humping
like it I would just jerk you've always
been a kind of a jerker I had been yet
it wrecked me what was it do you
remember the first time you married yes
my friend and I were showing each other
our penises under a Hulk doll like we
made the Hulk doll Incredible Hulk The
Incredible Hulk big what's that you
wanted your dick David but it was wrong
collar Hulk was green but you know what
we suspended disbelief and we're kind of
looking so there's penis isn't blowing
each other and I almost came in his
mouth but I was like why didn't would I
didn't know what it was and I ran to the
bathroom pointing my dick over the
toilet and then when he went home I
tugged it yeah and came have we heard
this story before I don't know if you
have or not but that's Travis this is
familiar to you The Hulk part is
familiar I don't know if the rest of I
know especially didn't know that was the
first time he came off that I jerked off
I've told no but you jerked off the it
was preceded preceded by your friend
blowing you yes for the Hulk but he was
full-on the Hulk not me okay we are in
two [ __ ] potential queers exploring
up our sexuality no no no no no we're
just both straight not each other yeah
have you ever tried to do an animated
show like naked everybody be like we
can't away I'm not exaggerating
go watch big mouth we could do that I
mean we couldn't do like little kids
sucking each other's dicks directly
bright but if you block it with a halt
doll yeah there it gets pretty it's
pretty like you know it's on Netflix so
it is pretty dirty I mean right it is
quit like they have truly let us do
everything like last season we have a
bit where the hormone monster that I
also voice that andrew has is the it's
the you know the voice that's just like
2 to 7 you know suck the Hulk's cook
Ginny
that was basically there's a moment
where he skull fox the
severed head of Garrison Keillor so we
we you we go we go to those places which
has been incredibly fun and it's the
beauty of being on Netflix they kind of
like yeah go for a minute sounds good do
you miss Broadway are you happy to not
be doing that schedule because it seems
really I mean I miss it I had the
[ __ ] best time it was like the but it
was the best gig I miss it I don't mind
it I didn't I don't like that schedule
was not bad you were working like you
know we were working like three four
hours a night and you just you know we
would be living in the city and walking
uptown and doing that show and your show
is one of the few that you could kind of
mix up and yeah different guests yeah we
did a different guest every night so it
kind of felt new every night and also it
was me and John we had written it so it
was kind of like it kind of just doing
stand-up in one place like where it's
like we don't have to if we don't
remember the lines then we changed the
lines there's no director after it's
being high the line is dot you know so
it like it was the best gig and and
honestly being able to do it with
someone like if I had been on my own I
think I probably would have like gone a
little crazy but just the idea that I
was doing it with my friend every night
was the best it was so fun matinees he
might the worst part of that doing
during the day yeah we had we had five
show weekends we'd have a Friday night
show and then to Saturday to Sunday and
that was pretty exhausting we didn't do
like a Wednesday matinee cuz I like we
were just like ain't no old ladies
coming out I see oh hello yeah but I
loved it I would I would do it I would
do it again in a heartbeat
yeah it's a very funny show yeah it was
great why don't you redo it or do you
want to do it again we might go do we I
think we're like we're figuring out what
the next version of something would be I
think we would love to go write another
one it's just you know like we we
finished that I went back to do big
mouth John went on tour and it's just
trying to find that enough time where
you're sitting in the same city in the
same room to be able to write the next
one so I mean I would love to do another
one it was really fun
how was a Diddy to work with get him to
the Greek he was great I mean he was
like he was it was he was largely
indifferent to all of us
then and then I told him about like he
was talking about how he liked to go to
the spa like the Russian baths in New
York and I was like oh you got to go to
this one in LA and I told him about a
place and he all sudden was like oh he
kind of like all of a sudden was like
alright you you have information for me
this is good huh and he was he was very
nice after that I mean he was always
nice I mean it's like it's Diddy he want
it was I think there was a brief period
of time where he was like I think I
might go become an actor and and he
showed up he was like I need to behave I
need to be good I need to be ready and
and then and so he was he was on great
behavior and then I think he was like oh
being an actor kind of sucks in the
field didn't they do a remake of that
yeah or he might remember in the wrong
cornea movie he was maybe a Raisin in
the Sun idea right yeah yeah that's the
one
yeah I mean it's pretty close raisin son
but which was a nun one sister act 2 and
that was really good then the first one
because rare yeah Lauryn Hill and the
second one is she yeah she's like the
cool girl and the second one but I yeah
he was but I do think he literally was
like couldn't be an actor and then I
think a lot of people I'm gonna be an
actor and then you're like I hope being
on set sucks it's boring all day good to
sit down come back hammer problem yeah I
think it's like I get it you're like I
get people don't like I don't know this
to us and for a CEO like him to me at
the whim of somebody else at all times
because actors are just like waiting for
instructions Yeah right he's like I
think I'll go and own Ciroc I'll do that
you know it instead of saying some line
written by some annoying Jewish guy I
think I'll just own a vodka Empire yeah
it seems like an easier way to make a
living yeah yeah I would say so
cuz you don't have to be somewhere
having to be somewhere is what stinks
having to be there early
yeah really like if you're at a certain
level I imagine you can say you don't
want your call to has being before
whatever I guess yes but I think it's
yet I remember like my first job in New
York I was a PA I'm like a commercial
and I remember like driving one of those
cube trucks like in through New Jersey
being like I hope this makes it under
the bridge you know when you're driving
you like a height thing like
[ __ ] I hope this thing does not scrape
the bottom of this bridge and I remember
being like all right its 7:30 calling
the office being like so I want to wrap
up because I got a dinner at 8:00 and
they're like what [ __ ] you talking about
like I was like oh it was the first
realization of like oh this is not my
time yeah none of this is my time and
and it really doesn't change very much
so did you want to be an actor or a
comedian to start I think I don't know
if I knew growing up like I didn't know
you could actually do this like I was
like I know there are people like actors
and I know there are people on centering
live but I didn't know like one could
actually go do it but I think I kind of
wanted to be I think I don't know I
think I wanted to be famous when the
right kid
and then I was like oh I like I want to
be funny and then I started doing improv
and and in college and was like oh that
I love doing this is the first thing
I've ever done that I just want to do
and then it was like oh I think I also
want to act I want to be able to do both
and and it's kind of been this effort to
like do all of those things and then and
then now being able to do animation I'm
like oh this is kind of the one of the
best things to do so once you started to
figure out what you like once you find
improv and you start to hone in on like
this is what I want to do yeah does the
I just want to be famous things start to
dissipate in favor of I want to do this
order you still going like I want to do
this to be famous well I think once you
start to get famous you realize like
it's not that fun
yeah like it's not bad sometimes but
it's also like I think that's like the
great fallacy of American society is
that like wealth and fame or think are
the thing that we're all quiet Li's not
everybody but largely it's like no go go
go like a go pursue wealth and fame and
then like you're like and I don't think
we take into account you're like oh it
seems like almost every famous person is
miserable like oh that right like
everybody Odie's you're like every
famous musician dies very young yeah
you're like maybe there's a correlation
there well the only thing worse than
wealth and fame is poverty and anonymity
[Laughter]
it really is a you curve we're going for
one or the other we don't we don't
really realize that somewhere right in
the middle is that sweet spot but
everybody gets to the middle and they
think they're only halfway there so they
keep going yeah and that I think
honestly that is kind of the beauty of
animation is that like for me it's like
I get to make the show I get to
creatively do everything I want to do
and it's not my face every day all day
on camera right and so when you're on
the street it takes people an extra
second to be like oh yes they really
have to be like I know who you are
I like versus just be like yeah you know
like but I mean look I still love doing
that and I still honestly love being
kind of famous but you know what I mean
it's just weird it's like this weird
thing where you you strive for it and
then you get it and it's actually it can
be kind of more complicated than you
think well there's a level you hit like
I was walking in last night and two cops
stopped hey we're family
yeah and but you can still walk into and
gives a [ __ ] yes that level of well you
can't go anywhere and that's probably
when we've seen it we've seen it with
people that yes and worked with it and
it's like it's just tricky man it just
gets to a point where like your life is
no longer your own you you have you have
new wittingly or unwittingly signed some
social contract that you're like yes I
get to fry fly privately wherever I go
in the world but wherever I go in the
world or wherever I go in this country
ten people are going to stop and talk to
me no matter what I'm doing who I'm
talking right and it's a real like it's
a real kind of weird contract like you
have to be able to afford the nicest
house possible because you can never
leave your house but that and that's the
thing is like what's that life you know
like what is that life being anger being
you're like secluded home but you get a
bunch of free [ __ ] to you do which is go
all the Lube you want right you get tons
of Lube you get whatever you whatever
you mentioned publicly if you're like I
use this Lube that's for life I know I
don't mention good things I should
mention trips and hotels let's talk
about Lube and rx bars [ __ ] [ __ ]
what do you remember the first girl you
met doing stand-up like the first time
you met a girl from being a professional
comic or improv
I've my whole thing with women has
always been before I was famous so tied
to being funny it was like so much of
what my currency was that I don't I will
I will say this I did like a little
while back this is now a few years ago
where I was like oh being it was a woman
that I had known for a while was I
didn't pick her up but like and she'd be
very really beautiful and we went home
and we had sex and then she called her
parents this was like 2:00 in the
morning called her parents put me on
speakerphone and said mom dad I just had
sex with a Jewish boy and this was with
her parents who were in the middle of
the country at like you know in the
middle of the night and island girl
named Eva it was one of the most bizarre
it was truly bizarre I was like this
feels very weird how did they respond
they were like a we on speakerphone oh
they were like this isn't the first time
that they had had this happy yes cuz it
was a black guy
there was a Jewish guy Spanish guy what
she was just doing something to get a
reaction of mother and father well they
were actually Jewish so I think it was
it was still a reaction but I think
there was like she was hoping that they
would be proud or something like that I
got their approval right whatever it was
I was like I don't I don't like this
like this feels weird that I am a I felt
being I felt used so I do you remember
the first girl I do yeah but it was it
was it was very infrequent it would
happen even have sex with her we didn't
do anything but it was the first time I
could have but her brothers kind of
cock-blocked it really he's awful
looking yeah so wasn't attracted I
wasn't great either
she rubbed my leg under the table I'd
never had a girl do that before was
after a set somewhere in Connecticut or
whatever and I don't have I've ever been
more turned on so I was like this is
from being a comedian like me yeah crazy
yeah right and I we were gonna go out to
the car and fool around and her brothers
were standing in the doorway watch it
was just it didn't happen so what are
you sure the brothers didn't want to get
in there get get the whole it would have
been more than what's a superhero
[ __ ] kid yeah
yeah that was abut that was just from
being man oh I didn't want nowhere we
didn't hook up we didn't upset but just
for from being funny the fact that that
happened